why should i trust you he's ready you  sure you got this  make me proud  you guys were in the zone i know great  game coach  i'll be right back  this is what father wants  [Music]  we've got no eyewitnesses except you  it's your word against his this kid  murdered my daughter  you can run this world if anybody tells  you otherwise you know what to do  you know where i can get a gun step into  my office  you look like you know what you're doing  it was a marine  that was a long time ago  you picked a hell of a crew to start a  fight with  you were supposed to watch his back  get everyone  i want to go hunting  get it over with  they took everything from me and it's  only a matter of time before they do it  to somebody else  you don't think that i know this town  just one man  just kill him you can't kill what's  already dead  yo man you bringing me some noise got no  choice  incoming load up it's about to pop off  that was exciting say hello to my son  you